foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to another amazing
episode of careful boys where we're
extremely careful and today we have Mr
Andy Wing in the hottest seat in the
house let's welcome back everybody
[Applause]
he is the owner of bored and hungry what
are the other things you are involved in
uh uh matte black coffee
um Hello Kitty cafe in Las Vegas
and a bunch of other [ __ ] you sold so
many stores ice cream damn all this
stuff you have your hands everywhere
very cool entrepreneur in the streetwear
game but now you have your ass in the
hot scene welcome what we like to do is
obviously we want to get close you want
to ask some you know burning questions
it might heat up a little bit hopefully
it does but we're gonna start off real
cool and gradually get there so Martin
started off with a super cold question
just so you can feel a little chilly all
right and then we'll make our way to the
warmth ready let's do it see this
which finger is this
dude this guy's a genius this guy's good
and that was a different style he
usually I'm just asking you a verbal
question not an actual physical thing I
really bring it into a different
dimension here I got smart man he just
how did you know it's a ring finger what
the [ __ ] what um don't answer that what
got you into entrepreneurship
I was trash in school
and I wanted to work with my friends
so that's why I decided to do it and it
just went from there and it never
stopped it never said
yo you're married with kids right now
yep married uh and two kids two girls
two girls yeah how long have you been
married five years five years how many
girls you bang before you get married
[ __ ] Jesus
I just want to measure the room yeah you
just kind of see where it says she's
sending her divorce papers right now
it just comes out of the fax machine in
the back we've got it right
[Laughter]
oh man so I saw you
um work with Snoop Dogg on the thing
like how did that connection happen so
snoop's son Cordell saw the
announcement of the board and hungry
concept and he's been heavy in web 3. so
he reached out DM me and we kept talking
from there he actually showed up to the
grand opening day
and then a week later he gives me a call
he's like
hey Andy I got my dad on the line I was
like what oh [ __ ] and so I'm talking to
Snoop right now on this you know I don't
even know I was going to be talking to
him
does he still say Fizzles but when you
do talk to him he does sound like sucks
recording a song all the time hey what's
up
[Laughter]
my name is Cordell pup
he doesn't even call his dad like he
calls everyone calls Snoop Dogg dog if
you're in the circle you call him dog so
he calls it down oh [ __ ] he doesn't call
him daddy nope oh did Snoop call you
nephew he did hey nephew hey what's up
nizzle
he was talking about doing a dessert he
want to do a dessert concept and then
you should do corn dogs dude dude that's
right up his alley he should do corn
dogs he might be already working on that
really wow yeah they want to do a
dessert concept off his uh boarding
character and so now we're helping him
launch a story out in Inglewood across
from Sofi Stadium no way whoa shooting
to launch by NFL season the start of NFL
season whoa yeah and he's also helping
us you know him then he jumped he wanted
to work on the food Fighters nft side
with us so we just gotta cross the deal
but we we premiered the brand at eight
Fest in New York City uh a few weeks ago
that's tight I saw him uh was he the one
like
um DJing the VMAs and then he was
wearing like a board a sweater yeah he
is all about his character I was like oh
[ __ ] I didn't know he was so deep into
the web 3 space but I guess that's
probably all part of like a big
overarching campaign it's actually one
of the first people to get super deep
into the web you know you know who
actually introduced him to the web 3
space Martha Stewart crypto and web
Martha Stewart so she was she was up in
it first she's the one that guy was he
up in her just out of here I don't know
about that you didn't ask him what
you're talking to him that's the
question of the century yeah yeah Martha
dog yeah Martha Stewart actually put
them on but being in the office with
Snoop the first time I didn't know he
was going to come into I was at his
compound and we're in a meeting and I've
already been there a few times they
still never showed up this one he just
randomly walks in like 30 minutes into
our thing already I turned around I was
like oh [ __ ] he's actually here I've
been there for an hour and just talking
to him I'm looking I was like man is
this real right now what's going on does
he see walk into the building I wanted
to see walk around the building
but it is a lot of there is a lot of
blue he spells everything he wants to
say yeah that is his whole wall like
encrypt like bandana print and stuff
there's a poker tables all Crypt again
the floor is a blue it's a blue floor
did you mean his designated blunt roller
yeah yeah we met I met her during a
we've shot a podcast interview there and
she's just she's just in the room
rolling the whole time I didn't know and
I figured out the end I was like oh
that's she's the one she's the one
that's rolling 24 7 for them whoa that's
so cool oh it's a lady yeah there's a
lady probably more delicate touch you
know what I mean I didn't know that like
70 plus Grand a year or does he have
different rollers all the time possibly
I just saw her I've just seen her so far
oh yeah she's in the room while
interviewing she's sitting in the back
in terms of all of your and I know this
is gonna be a very loaded and
complicated question so just like
whatever comes to mind but like uh what
are some of the highlights and you're
just like entrepreneurial Journey like
things like meeting Snoop Dogg opening
this what are certain things that you
just like considered maybe like top
three top five moments uh in your own
journey I think just biggest things that
have changed my life was getting kicked
out of school and getting back into my
high school a year later it was getting
back into high school that's that's a
big moment in my life which changed a
lot of my confidence level
I think that was a pivotal point where
it led me to where I'm at today what
what yeah what happened there get kicked
out for it and then like the going back
I got kicked out because Mike I was
failing every single class that required
anything with reading I only do class
two classes I was passing basketball and
choir everything else is FFF like sounds
like all of us
and then when you went back to school
what made you like have the confidence
so I was stuck at home my entire
sophomore year so I was pretty much
living in a pandemic already at that
time for myself right but I lived across
right across the high school I went to
not to look outside the window every
single day well all your friends are
leaving and socializing right and I was
like okay my first my freshman year was
like the worst I was getting bullied all
year I was getting in fights I was
getting suspended I had the worst grades
and it's just like okay I don't want to
be here and then when I was stuck at
home the first week you're like cool I
don't have to do anything and then week
two three passes by and you see your
friends having a good time and you don't
got [ __ ] internet like the way that
we have today actually it's boring
you're watching MASH on TV you're
watching all the songs
yeah these I Love Lucy every day dude
[ __ ] little house on Prairie The Andy
Griffith Show Golden Girls Maury all
kind of fire though nightmares here in
these shows so stuck for a home for a
year you start you know thinking about a
lot of different things and I was like I
just I just want to be around people
I want to be around people and I was
like I'm gonna do whatever it takes so
either I can finish
um continuation school and go to college
early or I'll just just try to get my
way back in and I decided to go back in
how did they let you back in school you
just had to get my grades up and go back
go back to the vice principal to kicked
me out so their disciplinary system
worked for Andy not for me I ran away I
came back completely I came back with
different you know attitude and so
they're different start participating
any club any school club I was joining
everything I was like I just want to be
at school as long as I can what city was
this in Westminster no Miami I think
that stuff helps you um like just being
in all the clubs helped you with
streetwear and like brand building and
all that yeah I think just being around
people just learning how to you know
talk to other people and socialize and
now you know now you're building this
character and brand for yourself so what
was another landmark especially in your
entrepreneurship Journey where you're
like oh [ __ ] like I can do this or we're
doing it um but the clothing brand was
was a big part of it right because I
can't you know I'm just a kid from
Little Saigon and the next thing you
know
um doing collaborations with all these
big Brands and all these working with
all these rappers and those are things
that you don't picture as a kid you're
like how's this gonna happen because
when I was when I was going to college
and I was taking career planning classes
figuring out where I wanted to go
they're making take all these surveys
right and all the survey my head I'll
think I was like I want to be a sports
agent I'm gonna be a music producer a r
or something and then the things that
came out were like office admin like
janitorial work it was literally said
that and I was like oh [ __ ] I'm not
doing this yeah so you would have been a
sick janitor probably probably swag that
one right sick it's just Street brooms
gold-plated [ __ ] mops and [ __ ] yeah
the clothing thing was pivotal for me
and I think after the the early success
of Afters is actually also very pivotal
because
those are unexpected things that happen
and when I did clothing I thought if
this clothing thing didn't work out but
I don't know what I'm gonna do
afterwards but once afterwards took off
I was like now I got the confidence
levels like anything were to happen I'm
gonna figure it out especially in that
spread right if you can do [ __ ] a
T-shirt and then you can make an ice
cream flavor that's like a very very
broad spread yeah so you kind of left
your comfort zone and you started from
almost like from ground up again but
then you took what you learned from
streetwear and then you got into food
that's tight it was just similar what
I'm applying now now I'm doing it into
nfts nfts I've got three yeah tying in
what I know from the past like all
everything and now leading into this
world and if I didn't go into the world
I wouldn't be what's working with Snoop
Dogg or you know Bun B and all these
people right now that's tights inner
entrepreneurial Journey what was like
the hardest time I think
the early success of Afters right after
that
being in the public eye so much at that
time and then launching other Concepts
that actually didn't work out oh [ __ ]
because things were moving so fast and
everyone's like throwing deals at you
yeah and now you're not making clear
decisions anymore you're just trying to
move as fast trying to keep the wave
going and then the media is just like
trashing me like eating me alive I'm
like what are you doing reading the
Articles and [ __ ] yeah of course I'm
reading everyone's sending it to me like
hey like look at those guys like what
were you getting trash for like I have
this noodle concept that we launched in
Little Saigon and you know I always
wanted to do a Vietnamese concept back
to the community but the concept just
the chefs weren't on board the partners
were stealing like a lot of things that
didn't work out we even had a car like
run to the store and then dip out and
everyone's like look look at these guys
just getting insurance money and going
buying themselves like supercars and
stuff like that but it was just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] up driver yeah whoa all
this crazy stuff was happening and then
the concepts itself weren't but you got
it yeah
tell me about the car so the the
consoles weren't coming out the way I
would execute normally I was like it's
not coming out to my quality yeah so I'm
just like getting burnt out at the times
like hey it's not fun anymore uh you
know I did this to change the game and
help uh build a community but now it's
like it's like firing back at me what do
you think caused all of that like one
after the other I think a lot of
egos amongst Partners
um
she's seeing too much big success too
early
was it the same team that you were
getting involved in or was it all these
other opportunities started coming in
you started a mix of both okay a mix of
both of it both of them and I think as
those 20 Stills 2016 so you know we're
just firing off in 2016 with all these
Concepts and everything going and then
Afters are still killing it but then I'm
dealing with like all these headaches of
all this other stuff it's like burning
money I'm like bleeding on all these
other things yeah and from there I was
like okay 2017 like I need to just take
a break you take a break and then
re-gather myself and if I'm if if I'm
not happy about the concept and I'm just
not gonna do it like I'm not confident
if it's not done right I'm just not
gonna touch it so was it like
um all these opportunities you don't
want to miss out so you jumped on it and
then later you're like I'm just gonna do
[ __ ] that I want to do that's dope I
think at that at that moment you're just
moving so fast and when things are
coming out you're like okay well I think
I can actually I can pull it off and
I have everyone's eyes on me right now
so I gotta I just gotta keep going so I
just keep moving do you feel like um
after all that now you can read people
better and see who's legit who isn't you
know that's that's always the tricky
part right yeah I probably better at it
yeah but some people are really good
salespeople yeah you find people along
the way but you also meet some amazing
people along the way that
that weren't my friends from before that
I'm working with now have become some of
my closest friends period yeah so that's
tight man it's hard to it's hard to
decide and who to work with and not not
work with because you want to keep the
opportunity open and you know my my
intention and goal is to help people
right like to help other people and and
provide opportunity for them and
sometimes sometimes it works out
sometimes it doesn't I don't like to say
that it's a good or bad thing it's just
everyone has their different version of
what success looks like and how like how
to get there is if you ever get in a
fight with your wife you know you know
who the [ __ ] I am
I'm not the boss at the work yeah at the
office the stores and stuff I'm like the
bot like you know No One's Gonna people
are scared even though I'm not I'm
prettier I think I'm pretty approachable
um but people obviously staff are scared
to talk to me
um but my wife she's the boss at home
you know if you meet my wife you'd be
like oh [ __ ] he's not dead you don't go
you don't know like how many stores you
have yeah you gotta hit her with that
yeah you can't say it's a Vietnamese
girl dude my ice cream's blue colors
your ice cream yeah I'm gonna ask you a
personal question obviously um foreign
because you've obviously worked with
both very very successful things and
also you know based off what you
describe things that maybe like didn't
work on a more personal level
um what do you because you obviously had
to work with different partners and put
yourself in different situations
different groups different types of
Brands what do you feel like you are
like best at and then what do you feel
like is something that maybe you weren't
so great at in those situations yeah I
think early on just when I was younger I
didn't understand how to be a leader
especially in my 20s like how you're
supposed to become like how are you
supposed to run a company of people that
are older and younger and you're just
like 20 30 people like how do you leave
like yeah you technically don't really
know how to do it because they don't
they haven't seen that successfully to
respect you in the first place right so
it takes a long time to to kind of go
through those um trials and tribulations
to make sure it's not working out later
um the things that I am good at I think
I'm great at
um having a good eye for design
understanding what which mix of
chemistry of different people that work
together I'm like a doc connector I'm
bringing like a lot of different groups
together to make sure things run
smoothly
I have a good knack for finding out
which locations are solid
um what brands kind of what type of
Brands will take off anything on the
front side of the house like marketing
branding design like that's what I'm
good at but when it comes to like hey
you have to deal with money or lawyers
I'm like can someone else do that it's
not my thing how did how did you like
discover that for yourself I just
whenever the topic of money came like
when we were sitting in conversations
like like talk about lawyers or money
you just see my attention I'm like Sonic
you guys figured I'm gonna get up and
walk out more time they just realize
there's no like okay Andy doesn't like
talking about that we'll just handle it
and you just wanted to play to your
strengths because you know you wanted to
know what you you know what you're good
at you want to stick around like cooking
I don't know how to cook I don't know if
you I always tell the guys we start a
concept don't ask me to come back in the
kitchen I'm I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna walk I'm just gonna pretend I
don't know what's going on if there's a
fire yeah
call the fire department call somebody
else don't call me
concerns they'll figure it out right
like you you kind of Know Your Role and
then you don't like
step on your partners who are like your
partners because they're good at that
you know so I think that's that's also
in the I've seen a lot of groups break
up because of like you got this dude
that's supposed to be an accountant in
the crew and he's trying to be a
creative and it's like stay in your
[ __ ] Lane shut up your idea is stupid
right you're like hey you know what
would be a good idea for your [ __ ]
comedy video shut the [ __ ] up dude
that's what I said to you yesterday man
I pitched my idea to you is how you [ __ ]
on me what the [ __ ] why don't you just
tell me what I'm saying and I'm not even
an accountant you're a fitness
instructor God damn it just make us buff
can you imagine that I mean make the ice
cream less sweet it's always an Italian
guy's cream in it there's the leaders
more ice cream
I got a great idea you put cookies and
you put [ __ ] cream together how about
that we're only doing ice cream after
what about before
nobody cares
too much black what is this
I know it's a difficult like having a
relationship with the entrepreneurial
lifestyle right how was that dating and
then like
managing that with your wife date when
we're dating life early on it was
definitely
Rocky right because what sort of back
does she does she uh work is she also an
entrepreneur she's a preschool special
teacher so her patience level is okay
just not with me but it's a different
that's the Vietnamese part save that for
the kids man but she's like like a nine
to five style well Summer's no right
yeah summer is off yes yeah yeah but
then but then like her her work style is
much more different because you could be
like oh 3am I gotta [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
right so how was that like in the very
beginning to get her to like understand
her I think she knew she understood what
she was signing up for because she came
in at the time when I was near the end
of I'm King leading into Afters right so
she saw like the entire process of how
this this went also you guys been
together for like a decade or something
yeah wow so she saw the process of a lot
of it and and I think she knew what she
was signing up for
um
it's definitely not easy but I think
over time especially when we started
having kids and then now I learned more
about like hey I need to block out those
hours I block out now and usually like 4
30 to 9 o'clock is my time with the kids
and if you call me I'm probably not
gonna pick up so you kind of shut out 4
P.M tonight you just have family because
work's gonna still be there I think
before I had kids I was still gonna I
was working like a madman once the kids
came I was like okay well now I gotta
give them attention and so kids make
everybody lazier huh got lazy after
Tycoon everybody everybody man with all
of your experience with all of your
knowledge and stuff like that what's
something that uh one you really want to
do moving forward uh you don't have to
you know disclose anything you don't
want to or and then also what's
something you would like never want to
do again that you've already done
never went I don't want to do the things
I've already done
so you always want to do some new [ __ ]
yeah because it doesn't what's what's
the point like when I talk about food
when going moving forward all the times
like hey like what am I really trying to
prove like what's like what's my end
goal I'm I'm looking at different
Industries how do I disrupt how do I
make how do I make build better
communities like there's different
disrupt dude you just exit it after now
you make the fours and you just roast
them oh you gotta do after URS After
Earth or currently currently you just
gotta do a currently ice cream
like those guys are after us okay so you
don't want to do anything you've done
before uh what's something you want to
do moving forward uh that's it's hard to
say right it's always looking I'm always
looking I'm always keeping my eye out at
different Industries like I didn't know
I was gonna end up in web 3 and nfts one
year ago was like nfts were like one
year out the other I was okay whatever
stupid jpegs and profile pictures
everyone's flexing because I know what
I'm not gonna I don't have time to get
into this I'm opening restaurants did
you ever get into crypto or did you go
straight into nft I I went pretty much
went straight into nfts wow even that
process of like learning about it and
going to it like obviously I was so
excited because I saw so much impact and
the speed of impact and how how much
void they're still in that in that game
so that's why I wanted to jump in that's
tight but learning how to buy board ape
and everything at that time was like a
complete night that was a nightmare dang
what's something that like
um
you commonly hear or you've heard
commonly before as like this is kind of
the standard in business or this is a
rule and business that through your own
experience like man that's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
doesn't work like that do you have to
have money just yet you know you have to
have money to start you know to do this
I think a lot of people they don't do
things with like you need you need money
like I don't I'm not gonna do this
because it requires this much I'm like
it's not true like I started after
that's been 15 grand I made that back in
a week
so this to all this to this day 14
Brands a lot to people he's like I got
that pocket right now College costs even
more yeah that's true if you work a
minimum wage job in a year you could
save that if you're working if you live
at home it's not that unreasonable if
you live at home work minimum wage don't
have any other things you can maybe say
15. yeah so that brand that brand has
been built independently to this day
there's no there's no franchise owners
for it it's still it's so crazy and we
grew it you know we grew it through just
self-funding it from that one additional
15 grand you just kind of cycled it over
and over and over yeah we just you know
we just took a lot what we learned we
learned a lot of things from reset even
from the recession right we pulled like
hey let's keep things tight let's not
spend stupid money let's let's just try
to be smart with it you know and then
applying a lot of that just happened to
work in 2014. I was like Hey we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna build this off
of social media and let's try it out
that's tight dude that's really cool
congratulations thank you
wait for After Earth and currently
currently ice cream currently
[Music]